this is illumi zoldick this is not
illumizoldic because this is a lie so
let's find out why hello and welcome to
the new world review source for
everything anime and manga my name is
liam or is it i mean i i could be lying
for all you know but today we're here to
discuss one of the more mind-blowing yet
shockingly credible theories in all of
hunter hunter and if you've never heard
it before it's going to sound absurd at
first but this is the idea that hisoka
is illumi not throughout the entire
series but that this illumi this one in
particular the one that we're following
right here and now in the current manga
this guy is hisoka and i'm sure that
many margaritas would have heard or even
had this thought before now because
well what else have we got to think
about right now but i've always found it
to be something of a cute idea for
hisoka to be deceiving the phantom
troupe just waiting for his chance at a
rematch with crollo aboard the black
whale one and there's always been some
pretty decent evidence to back it up as
well a lot of which has come to me via
twitter from a user named yuki and i'll
have a link to her channel in the
description because in addition to
thinking about hunter hunter she also
makes very very cool musics however
these few extra pieces of evidence
brought to my attention have completely
changed my thinking of what i once
thought was nothing more than a cute
idea but i am now close to 100 convinced
that this is not illumizoldic and by the
end of this video i think that you'll be
in the same position and right now you
are also in the position to subscribe to
the new world review which will result
in consistent injections of hunter-based
culture administered directly into your
youtube feed highly beneficial to any
hunter so press the red button join our
association and do say hi in the
comments below if you're new to the
channel welcome but let's get into some
much needed context for those of you who
have not read the manga events beyond
the anime or for those of you who have
just kind of forgotten what's going on
during the longest hiatus the series has
ever endured here is the swift tldr
while everyone else was preparing for
the dark continent voyage he selka
fought against chrollo in heaven's arena
the fight was amazing it's one of the
best combat sequences i've ever read in
manga but it resulted in crollo's
victory and he managed to quite
literally kill hisoka however just prior
to his death hisoka made a heartfelt
plea to bungee gum and programmed it to
revive him after death which it did and
due to the concept of post-mortem nan
hisoka's non-abilities received a
significant power boost afterwards which
is important because it forms the
technical backbone of this theory
justice sisoka's abilities form the
literal bungee bone of his new body
parts in any case a newly revived hisoka
then went on to kill both charnock and
cortopia which incurred the anger of
chrollo and the rest of the crawler
troupe so currently they are all hunting
for hisoka aboard the blackwell one and
causing chaos alongside all of the
succession war business oh anila me is
also there illumi has joined the phantom
troop the reason given being that hisoka
apparently paid illimi to put a hit on
himself which knowing he saw granilla me
look it's not at all out of the question
they are the kind of people who would
absolutely enter into that sort of
arrangement but the general thought of
this video is that this is not illumi
this is hisoka imitating enemy's body
with his newfound postmortem nan
abilities when he was resurrected hisoka
demonstrated the power to create false
body parts using bungee gum and make
them look entirely realistic with an
amped up version of texture surprise the
combination of which could theoretically
allow hisoka to mold his body into the
shape of illumi with texture surprise
plonked on top to complete the aesthetic
illusion which wouldn't be particularly
difficult because hisoka and illumi have
a similar physique as it is in fact
they're both almost the exact same
height as well hisoka is 187 centimeters
tall whereas illumi is 185 according to
the hunter hunter guidebook although in
the actual series crawler does state
that hisoka is over six foot two which
would be over 190 centimeters in
reasonable measurement units but it
doesn't really matter or does it
no
no it doesn't what matters a bit more is
what we haven't seen and something that
we have not seen is hisoka despite the
phantom troops confidence that he is
aboard the blackwell one neither we nor
they have actually seen him during the
succession wara and whenever hisoka's
not on screen everyone should be asking
the question where's hisoka which has
led the fanbase to the bizarre
outlandish conclusion that hisoka is
being a rather trixie hobbitses and
pretending to be illumi and i say
outlandish because that is what i used
to think not anymore though because
whilst this may look and sound like
killing me at a casual glance there is a
mountain of minor inconsistencies that
point to a very very different
conclusion and the first thing i would
like to point to is knee pads i'd never
really thought that knee pads would be
the key to anything in particular but
succession war illumi does undeniably
come equipped with them a seemingly
innocuous design feature at first glance
because this is illumi after all he is
weird and therefore he wears weird
things the interesting thing however is
that knee pads pods bads never had any
parts come on the interesting thing
however is that knee pads are actually
something of a hisoka trademark he's
worn them on at least two separate
occasions both of which were his
appearances in heaven's arena he wore
them in the series during the heavens
are in iraq where he famously fought
against gon but he also whipped them out
again to fight crolo in the same venue
meanwhile illumi has never once worn
knee pads in his entire hunt hunt tenure
and yet now here he is clearly garbed in
hisoka's trademark kneewear and yeah i
get it this is a very small thing and if
this was the only piece of evidence and
we just laughed this theory right out of
the association but it is one small
wildly curious choice made by togashi
alongside many many others the next of
which is illumi's speech now this is not
at all apparent to us in english but in
japanese illumi's speech patents are
quite inconsistent with his character
prior to the succession war with one of
the biggest of inconsistencies being
pronouns now this is something that once
again is not visible in the english
translation because we have a completely
different system to japanese but hisoka
and illami actually have very different
ways of referring to themselves for
example in english you would just say i
you know i did this or i did that or i
never get out of the house because i
spend all of my time talking about
fictional hunters in a very dimly lit
room whereas in japanese the very act of
saying i differs wildly based on a wide
array of varying factors such as gender
and formality social status whatever but
the most basic way of saying ai that
people are probably aware of is watashi
it's a very long way of saying aye so
long that more often than not it just
gets dropped from sentences entirely and
just implied but this is by far the most
neutral and polite in hisoka's case he
is neither neutral nor polite and has a
well-recorded history of using the
pronoun boku which to put it simply is a
less formal incarnation which is
generally used by young boys but not
exclusively but it is often seen as a
word that say a 12 year old boy would
fearlessly wield which makes a lot of
sense with hisoka because his character
is quite often playful and twistedly
childlike in nature illumi on the other
hand is significantly more blunt and
uses the pronoun order and ore is very
much the calling card of a confident
older male it is completely informal
it's considered to be quite rude in many
situations and it's actually perfect for
illumi because he has no filter in
addition to expressing little to no
emotion illemi's words tend to get
straight to the point there is no
messing around with him which all
becomes fascinating very fascinating
because accessible illumi abandons his
previous use of language and instead
uses boku whenever he refers to himself
instead of order now this might seem
really minor to us filthy
english-speaking swine but these two
pronouns carry very very different
connotations in japanese and so this is
unlikely to be a situation where tagashi
just kind of forgot what he set up
although to be fair that does also
happen but the bokus the ores the
wantashi's natashi so on and so forth
actually form very core parts of
japanese characters it helps us
understand who they are and the fact
right now is that the way illumi is
talking is much more in line with
hisoka's character than it is with his
and pronouns aren't everything in fact
illumi's general use of language is also
just very unlike him remember when i
said before that illumi is incredibly
blunt and to the point well those things
that i just said is what he is not doing
right now previously illimi didn't waste
time with fanciful metaphors or double
meanings which is why his words to the
phantom troop now are so fascinating
when speaking about his arrangement with
hisoka illumi refers to his assassin fee
as a prenuptial agreement or a prenup
for short which is already quite out of
character but what we really miss in
english is that this line comes with
accompanying furugana in japanese
furigana being a set of basic japanese
hiragana or katakana designed to let you
know how to read certain kanji and this
is necessary for many reasons including
the fact that the same kanji can be read
in several different ways depending on
the context in japanese but with
furigani can also construct all sorts of
clever language stuff and in this case
the furigana reads as engagement ring
like it literally says in geji mentoring
which is a very curious choice for
illumi at best and completely out of
character at worst whereas you could
certainly picture hisoka equating an
assassination fee to a sort of
engagement ring because that's that's
just what hisoka is and we're not done
because in addition to that and this is
something that is completely lost in
english but when speaking about the
phantom troupe illimi uses the word
konkai which translates to this time so
what he literally says is this time i
have joined the spiders at hisoka's
request this time implying that there
was maybe a previous time and of course
hisoka was once a member of the phantom
troupe so that would make sense if he
was sneakily referring to himself
although i should point out that the
phantom troop have actually hired
illinois before they paid him to
assassinate the ten dons during york new
city so this could also be referring to
that incident as much as we've not seen
them in the same location before now
illumi and crollow do have an
established working relationship this is
sort of so take the whole konkai thing
as you well admittedly it's not the
strongest piece of language-based
evidence but it is interesting to point
out if only because it was omitted from
the english translation to get out of
the world of language for a second
though one of the more sinister pieces
of visual evidence comes from the cover
of volume 36. here we have the full
current cast of the phantom troop hilly
included but scattered amongst them we
also have three flowers which assumedly
denotes the dead members two of which we
can assign to sharnok and cortopi
although the third is a very interesting
discussion either way smack bang in the
middle of this gathering we have illumi
equipped with knee pads and holding a
flower implying that illumi has some
sort of connection to the other flowers
on the cover which if we wanted to paint
in the hisoka theory colours we would be
implying that he was responsible for
their deaths and i honestly don't see
any other reason why togashi would
showcase illumi in this way according to
the information we have illemi's
involvement in the succession war was
purely intended to be bonus material a
plaything for hisoka to toy around with
while he kills the rest of the troop and
yet on this cover illumi is so
profoundly important given the central
spot directly connected to the flowers
and it can definitely be interpreted as
hisoka hiding in plain sight from the
troop and that's not all because apart
from feitan and bernoullinov who have
facial coverings illumi for whatever
reason is the only character on this
cover who is missing a mouth and it was
suggested by a reddit user named scene
underscore k that this relates to an old
japanese saying which translates to a
dead person has no mouth a similar
saying in english might be dead men tell
no tales which could also be a potential
reference to hisoka because he did the
death thing and you might think that
we're over valuing the significance of
illimi's missing mouth here and i would
agree were it not for the fact that
togashi himself makes it extraordinarily
significant at the beginning of the book
volume 36 starts with an author's note
the most simplistic author's note i've
ever seen actually which is a drawing of
a mouth and the words spoilers i dare
say so we found elemy's missing mouth i
suppose and his evidently softened
supple lips are saying that looking too
deeply into this may very well be a
spoiler everything about this cover is
meticulously crafted by togashi which he
does have a recorded history of doing
for example the cover of volume 30
featured all of the zodiacs and only two
of them with their hands behind their
backs those being paristan and saiyu who
ended up being the two to betray the
organization it's subtle so subtle that
it almost makes you think that you are
the crazy one until togashi comes clean
and eventually does reveal the answer in
this case the cover and the author's
note are more brazen than any that have
come before it but one question i do
have is regarding the three flowers for
the illumi as he soaked her idea to work
this would imply that hisoka is
connected to three deaths but
deciphering the third is not necessarily
that straightforward karapika was the
clear cause of death foo of agin and i
would say the same for pakunoda but in
the past hisoka did defeat another troop
member who held the number 4 spot and
while it was never explicitly stated
that he killed that member i don't
really see many other outcomes in which
that battle would have concluded so that
could be our three dead troop members
shall not cortopia and the former number
four all slain by the bungalicious hand
of hisoka the other way you could
interpret this cover is a reference not
to the past but to the future this could
be telling us who hisoka is going to
kill which would make sense with the
lips of the volume warning us about
potential spoilers and if you were to go
by who the flowers were closest to that
would be finks kalato and either shizuku
or franklin that's the simplest way to
look at it anyway i suppose you could
also analyze the flowers by color or
however you like but that's the general
idea that they are there and they mean
things either way the flowers represent
dead troop members or they foreshadow
future deaths of troop members and
whatever the case may be they are
connected to illumi a man who has
absolutely no reason to be involved in
such connections but if this is hisoka
then firstly this is sinister half and
secondly it makes all the sense in the
world but i'd also like to bring up a
scene in the mangrove villami's
conversation with mizeistom after the
troop decide to split up illimi and
kalato get rather hilariously caught
almost immediately after which point
illumi requests a cell with a shower now
this is i will admit some glorious
overthinking i warn you but illumi has
never been the type of person to be
overly conscious of his own cleanliness
i mean the dude even slept in a hole
that one time on the other hand frequent
bathing is practically another hisoka
motif such as when we dwell on him
showering at heaven's arena but we do
also intrude on him bathing a greed
island he may be a sick twisted
degenerate thirsty battle clown but at
least he's a clean clown i'll grant that
this is probably one of the most
outlandish connections of the video but
at the same time illemi's words once
again they're just very out of character
illumi is not the kind of person who
wastes words requesting a room with a
shower that he doesn't need and during
this conversation illumi also gives up
the information that the entirety of the
phantom trooper aboard the ship which is
information that he volunteers
volunteers being a very key word because
illumi does not volunteer especially if
it's relevant to his current job i
really cannot emphasize enough just how
flippant and reckless illumi is being on
these pages and how it is very unlike
the illumi that we know now let's get
into some of the issues with this theory
because carlito has been brought up a
couple of times and he does present a
potential problem hisoka might be able
to fool the troop into thinking that
he's illimi but kalito as a brother of
illemi should probably know better i
mean yeah they're quite a few years
apart they probably don't spend a ton of
time together but in theory karlito
should probably be able to recognize
that philome is acting slightly
naughtily so to account for that we may
need to get a little bit more convoluted
we either need to suggest that carlato
has no idea whatsoever an incident is
just kind of meh writing or that kalato
has no strong connection to illumi
despite their brotherliness or that
kalato does know and he is in on the
clever ruse it's not too far out of the
realm of possibility because carlito has
no real loyalty to the troop he's only
there for the very vague mission of
getting his brother back the meaning of
which is a gigantic question in and of
itself and in fact i have a whole video
discussing that issue which i do
recommend checking out but all hisoka
really needs to do is promise to assist
kalato just as he has done in the past
notably would say karapika during york
new city but this does require that
extra layer of thought and if this were
any other series i wouldn't even bother
to go that far but togashi does engage
in these kind of complex cerebral
scenarios so for better or worse nothing
is ever off the table in hunter hunter
and even with it on the table the
evidence is reaching a critical mass
tagashi has dripped in enough subtle
hints to paint a beautifully
foreshadowed picture without completely
giving away the game illumi speaks like
hisoka his design incorporates one of
hisoka's trademarks hisoka does have the
technical ability to make this a reality
and togashi is heavily suggesting that
there is something very off about illumi
in regards to the author's notes and
cover of volume 36 at this point i would
be much more surprised if this actually
was illumi although that's not off the
table either there could exist a
situation where two things are true and
dilemmy is working with hisoka whilst
hisoka is impersonating enemy and
they're both just running around and
doing stupid clown things there's
definitely a lot of different ways this
could go but the one piece of certainty
we have is that this illumi is not what
he seems and i am convinced that this is
actually hisoka in disguise but if you'd
like to examine another fun hunt
hunter's theory then i have another
video that details the history and logic
behind the feitan is actually a zoldic
theory i know it sounds pretty absurd
but hey so did this video and there's a
good deal of substance to it so i look
forward to seeing you there